the ideal length of a why a novel word
counts what's the typical length and
then if you stretch it what's to be
expected yeah that's actually a great
question and that's something I obsessed
about when I was writing because I write
long books I tend to always write very
long so I know other people struggle
with writing shorter and their word
counts being low I would say the sweet
spot at least in my opinion is somewhere
between seventy five thousand and eighty
five thousand words for contemporary y-a
which would be a story told in the here
and now you will see books that are
shorter so I think you get away with
even sixty-five thousand words or
obviously longer than that if you start
to go above a hundred thousand words and
my book definitely does and they do the
first book I believe is somewhere in the
hundred and five thousand word range
which is comparable to something like
Hunger Games and as the series
progresses where you will get more
leeway in word count they do span
upwards I'm looking at closer to hundred
twenty thousand on the third book but
like I said when you're doing big world
building genre books sci-fi fantasy you
do get more leeway on word count
regardless of genre so you can get away
with something that is over a hundred
thousand words if you've never sold a
book before and you're going on
submission I would caution you against
I'm doing anything that's too much
longer than 100 105 thousand because
that's a pretty hefty book but that said
I mean everyone you know has sold things
that you know are of different lengths
and you know I always think that the
word count should justify be justified
by the story so I did learn that when
you write multiple POVs that will
pollute baloon your word count so that's
why Game of Thrones is so long I have a
lot of empathy for george RR martin but
there's a reason why his books are
spanning over a thousand pages you know
because once you starts telling all
those multiple stories it really is
going to expand it so but yeah but so
the sweet spot of word count is going to
be somewhere in those ranges